over the past few weeks in afghanistan
we've been to secret schools
where young girls risk arrest doing
clandestine art classes
we've heard from scores of fathers
who've solved their kidneys just to feed
their families and then push their wives
into doing the same
[Music]
we've reported on badly burned toddlers
in hospital in danger of dying because
their families can't afford the bandages
we've seen the taliban's new
intelligence unit in operation
controlling the streets
and prisons crammed full of men and
children who say they've been put in
jail without proof or trials or any
evidence
we've seen the women demanding their
rights disappear
and their videos shouting for help
dismissed as faith the ministry of
interior absolutely rejected it
and we've witnessed long long queues of
people urgently needing food
and begging for help as the country
hurtles towards a humanitarian
catastrophe
but in a country with so many suffering
so much it was our journey to the north
west province of bad geese which shocked
the most
the winter chill has brought fresh
levels of suffering to a people who've
endured decades of it
but in one of the poorest countries its
porous region may well be the birthplace
of the world's largest humanitarian
disaster
five years old
seven years
nine years
six years old these are girls already
sold into marriage many too young to
even know their own ages
eight years they're often prompted by
their guardians
six years the husbands they'll go to are
a decade or more older the last to talk
is five years old
the youngest in her father's arms is a
seven-month-old baby given in lieu of
medical bills
the girls have no say
this in one of afghanistan's poorest
villages
and the deprivation here means girls are
being sold into marriage earlier and
more often
there's not enough room in the tent for
all the parents who want to show us
their young daughters they've sold
we don't want to sell them she says but
we're poor and we have to eat
hajira had fetched an above average
price more than six thousand dollars
then she got injured and the deal was
called off
i'd already sold her to a family her
father tells us but they brought her
back when she got injured and said they
couldn't take care of her so i never got
any of the money
now he's on the hunt for another buyer
once final payments made for his eldest
daughter she'll be sent to her new
family she wants to study and is too
young to question what's happening
my father sold me because we're poor she
tells us
that's what we're told time and again
and in this remote village it was hard
to find anyone who hadn't sold their
little girls as payment in kind to
settle debts or just to buy food
some of the villagers are now living in
tents after an earthquake a few days
earlier which has reduced to rubble what
little they had
you can see
all the house has fallen down all the
exterior walls have fallen down and the
two children sleeping there died these
people were struggling before but nearly
six months after the taliban took
control the country's economy is
collapsing
and those like gulsha who thought life
couldn't get any harder are telling us
it can and just has
she sold her two-year-old girl satera
who she was still breastfeeding her
family was so desperate
with no food no water and lots of others
to feed she says what mother wants to
sell their children but there's no other
solution
the baby was returned because she
wouldn't stop crying but the family who
bought her say they'll be back when
she's a bit older now gulsha is trying
to find buyers for her two other girls
and she's not alone the extreme poverty
across afghanistan has led to an upsurge
in early or forced marriages for money
they've all pretty much sold daughters
in this deprived region girls are
reduced to possessions to be bartered
over
the remote villages in this corner of
badgis are very conservative and very
underdeveloped
and they've long been strongholds of
taliban support
but the taliban commanders and elders
here told us
they want the international community
back
not the military but the foreigners help
so he's happy to see international
people back in afghanistan again
we want the international community to
come to afghanistan to help us the
commander tells us and since the taliban
came to power there's no security
problem for anyone and we assure all the
foreigners about this in the future
but right now the humanitarian crisis is
hitting the country hard and
afghanistan's daughters are amongst
those suffering most
so the women of badgis queue for hours
just for free paracetamol for the sick
in afghanistan's most deprived province
nothing comes easy and everything's
scarce
desperation is the only commodity not in
short supply here
they're having to cram babies onto beds
in the main provincial hospital
it's standing room only here
a measles outbreak is ripping through
them in the tiny with already poor
immunity measles can be a death sentence
the insecurities meant vaccines haven't
been given
and there are widespread claims it's the
taliban who prevented them
the number of measles here is very high
the doctor tells us we don't know how to
help them he says it's very hard for all
of us
the talib now in charge of health
services has no medical qualifications
and left school at 14. not so long ago
he was fighting foreign troops and
blames others for the current mess
everyone knows that previous president
ashraf ghani was the most corrupt person
in the most corrupt government in the
world he tells us and we have a lack of
everything
that means those who are least able are
losing this fight
erezzo breathed her last aching with
hunger and in a bitingly cold tent
her father traveled three hours to this
their nearest hospital
but no one can help his daughter now
the two-year-old's parents wrap up her
frozen body with the air of people with
no hope who never expected help and
didn't get him
we're living in tents her father says
some people don't even have tents where
we are there's no warm place and that's
why she died
there's no time for grief they've two
more children to keep alive
[Music]
there are too many la carreso who've
perished starving and cold
it never gets any easier
misery stalks every corridor and every
ward
she's already lost two other children
now rizzuma's youngest is only just
clinging to mine
cadia has a range of complications all
of them normally treated easily but
these are not normal times in a country
where little is functioning normally
right now
the baby has pneumonia measles a fever
and at the root of it all poverty and
little food
they bring in a nebulizer to help
[Music]
in a country where billions were spent
over two decades the young are suffering
terribly
later the same night after filming this
kadia also succumbed afghanistan's
babies are dying at a shockingly high
rate
in the maternity wards samaya and the
other teenage mothers edged towards
labour filled with fear
like asia she was sold into marriage at
14.
they're all living in a country with one
of the highest maternal mortality rates
every girl here knows surviving the
birthing experience will be one of their
toughest challenges
[Music]
finally trying to deliver her baby
there's no pain relief
there are few medicines at all here the
midwives must cut her if her baby's
going to be delivered alive
it's been a difficult and traumatic
delivery
and the baby is completely limp and
unresponsive
[Music]
i'm really scared the exhausted new
mother says
she's worried for herself and her
newborn son
she looks on as the midwives work fast
now
every second is going to count if this
baby is going to live
[Music]
he doesn't appear to be breathing
they frantically suck out the amniotic
fluid which is threatening to drown him
they have few medical tools to help them
save this baby
but my goodness they're using them as
best they can
they tie his umbilical cord
but he's not yet out of danger and still
not responding well he's taken to the
resuscitation room where there's a
rolling queue of babies needing help
they need to get more oxygen inside this
baby's lungs
but the hand comp is defective
most of these medics are working for
very little and have hardly been paid
since the taliban came to power and
foreign aid suddenly stopped
[Music]
but this little boy's battle to live is
their fight too both mother and baby
have somehow got through this but the
baby starts his life in a land where
most are hungry and the entire afghan
society is teetering on the edge of
collapse
alex crawford sky news